permettez à un vieux militaire de vous
dire que ce n'est pas avec tes bêtises
pareilles et je suis poli confrères
jeunes et sting de l'eau tradition est
fière de servir la patrie
recevez monsieur le directeur
l'expression de mes civilités fumette
expression de ses militarité mais enfin
c'est le capitaine bernard du cadre de
réserve de labastide murat dans le lot
mais aspect mon capitaine et bien est ce
que vraiment les shadoks sont un danger
pour la discipline c'est ce que nous
avons voulu savoir
nous avons interrogé des gens qui ont un
rapport direct avec la discipline des
agents de police et des militaires dans
votre matériel
non mais rend juste enchaîné votre
matériel monsieur une enquête justement
un peu partout pour avoir des réactions
de ce qui se passe dans les rivaux
harris étaient les miennes tout y est à
moi les miennes peut-être généraux du
matériel ou jouer en premier un rapport
salaires voir des seins nus est-ce que
vous avez la seconde chaîne
est-ce que vous avez la seconde chaîne
chaînes de télévision mais non j'ai pas
de pause de télévision vous avez pas les
télévisions n'ont même pas que je trouve
que c'était un peu enfantin fermeront
d'un pourquoi feu n'ont aucun sens pour
ainsi dire voilà qu'est ce qui vous
choque le plus c'est l'histoire c'est
les dessins ou c'est la v2 les deux
histoires et des saveurs et si on gère
une chaîne
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre à la place
je ne sais pas je suis pas qualifié vous
répondre ça lui ne me suis pas beaucoup
partition de ça vous savez c'est le sac
au sérieux je préfère voir un un bon
avant les sternes entrevue mme st-jean
scandale c'est pour se distraire un peu
mûri mais c'est vrai je vois beaucoup de
temps suite déjà labourés excusez pas
tort
j'ai 2 contre la violence à la
télévision non du tout non ça se raconte
à l'usm est plutôt sain ouais mais c'est
au prix oui j'adore que vous croyez
vraiment que l'échelle de c1 n'a rien et
ça plaît ou ça plaît pas et que vous
regardez vous les chaises oui je regarde
pour regarder mais ça me ferait pas
pressés tout qu'est ce qui vous plaît
pas dans l'échec est un peu un peu
loufoque
j'ai réussi à garder halak est ce que
vous pensez les chefs de glace était sur
la voie un quart voit c'est à revoir
pour
il faut continuer ça vous plaît qu
officiellement vous êtes pour les
shadoks
voilà pas de restriction vous trouvez
pas ça bête vous trouvez pas ça m'allait
ciné opéra sur toutes choses bêtes
durant l'entraînement par nature c'est
officiel c'est le rdr est fort possible
monsieur adressez vous à la préfecture
de police est alors une audition
l'humour nous nous n'avions droit à
l'humour n'est pas l'humour non je fais
une enquête sur le sur les programmes de
la deuxième chaîne au sujet d'une
querelle qui surgit à propos des shadoks
qu'est ce que vous avez déjà regardé les
chiens deuil qui a plus cours
1 on va appeler la police
schaller fait la police vous pour vous
les vendre